Welcome to Google Developers Show, a gold edition
where we are enjoying
with Felipe Hoffa
here next to me
the thecnological diversity.
We will ejony with
the audience the Massive Analysis
of Data, we will present BigQuery
We will work in Open Data,
specifically on the birth data
Felipe, an initial message and your presentation
to the audience of Google Developers
Nick how are you? Thanks for having me.
It’s been a great week in Mexico
and to tell you who I am,
I started at Google as a software engineer
three years ago
and a year ago I’m working as a Developer Advocate
where my job is to go
outside Google offices, being in blogs,
in Youtube, assit to conferences
to show you the Google tools that
an be used to make your life
easier
and to make your analysis more interesting
I work particularly in the area of BigData
and I love giving tools
for you to analyze
your information, the plubic information
and this week has been amazing.
We went to Presidency. We enjoyed
the Mexico ecosystem.
We’re very happy.
We had some events, and we’ll be having more this week
with the community ... If you want to see the video
we have the video conference
from UNAM. Here you can see the link.
So you can check the UNAM video
in this university congress.
It's very interesting because there was
very nice things to talk about.
Today we'll be discussing about Open Data using Bigquery,
We’ll be sharing a set of data
and we will download the data with Felipe,
from Mexico’s Open Data Portal
and we will process it, that what
we do, right? Exactly .. so, let’s do it.
Ok, let start! We will work then
on open data sets. First I want to introduce you to Mexico’s Open Data Portal
where we looked for some interesting data.
In this case, I looked for “Data”,
I clicked on the health data.
Here you can find all births occurred
between
2008 to 2013.
There are millions of births in Mexico
so in order to analyze this information
the first thing we need to do is
to get the data.
And what I did once I downloaded these
Data I upload it to BigQuery
to make it all easier.
I'll show you how to
download them from BigQuery.
We then go to 2008, right? Yes
Here I can copy the adress link, the URL
and with that I'm going to download it in
Google Compute Engine servers.
Perfect.I could do it in my house, but the internet
speed is faster there
Exactly so we will download the data, we will use
Compute Engine, Google Cloud and its potential.
Exactly
Tet’s do that
While I work, I’ll show you the console’s
developer where you can have your
own machine
and a button we added recently, SSH,
direct to the machine
through the web
It works fantastic, so I plugged it to my machine here
Here you’ll will find and also about Big Data,
BigQuery so we can see that
afterwards ... Exactly!
Under the file
Biquery cannot ingest Zip files. Ok ...
So I have to unzip
Now, I can also compres to .gz
because Bigquery reads it ...
So I simply unzip this file
With an unzip ...
With an unzip .. Very Good
I already have it decompressed
So let’s see what it has ... OK
Let's do a head SINAC_2008
.csv
Perfect!
You can see here .. the first row contains
each column name. Ok
That is the Header. Ok ...
And after each row are births
In this case from 2008
To upload these files to BigQuery
I have my command here that I had
loaded before.
Let's see step by step.
The first command is “BQ”…that’s how I tell Bigquery
to run.
This is the file that will put.
I have the option to skip to the
first row. Because the first
row is not data, it's just the name of each column
I put the name of my project, I put the name
of the data set that I already created.
Here is where I put all my files when I’m trying things.
They're all together there .. Exactly ..
and I left here the births of Mexico in 2008
From the file that we just downloaded.
As you can see I compressed it in .gz
to have a shorter transmition time…
and then I give
all columns that this file has.
Data of the mother, child data, weight,
etc ... geographic places ..
It is very interesting ...
This process could be done by the console
web also, right?
Exactly, yes. But what we are doing It through Console.
Exactly, especially with large files works better. Perfect!
But also you can go here and
upload the files we have. Perfect.
As I showed you
I left it all in a Public Tab.
Here you’ll find
a table for 2008, 2009
until May 2013.
and then, with a Query
I put them all together
in a single table that is
Births 2008 - May 2013.
We have all our columns. How many columns
to we have  of 2013 births? Because they are ...
from 2008 to 2013, Felipe .. there are many ..
How many columns or how many rows? How many rows!
Let’s see that… Very easy ..with a count
Exactly
Querys time and let’s have fun with data set
Then how many births have between 2008 and 2013?
Any bets out there ... Any bets?
Let’s go!
Let's make a start count
hmmm a million? More…10 million ?? 50 million?
Here we have 12 million births
in all these years…
Wow .. 12 million is a significant number ...
Very fast .. Ok…we did it!
We have then 12 million
rows, let’s see
how is the data .. we know where the mother was born ..
Ok ..the town of birth
year of birth
marital status
where she lives nowadays
how many pregnancies she had, the number of births
her schooling,
Where she works ...
and all data of the child that was borned.
Weight, size.
That's super important, size for example.
We could start playing
about
what regions of Mexico has bigger size
for example ...
Let’s find that out!
Let’s see first what is the average size
for all Mexico.. Exactly, It's important.
to see the average size.
Then again .. We can keep playing..50 cm? ..
49, 48? .. If I do not know what size I was born…
Is there information that tells us
the actual sizes based on censuses
and extrapolate with .. It would be very interesting
Exactly…
We could leave it also as a task sometime …Exactly ..
Now as you can see here in 2 seconds
I calculated the average size
50.69 centimeters in Mexico.
Ok, now let's see this in regions.
Region to region .. Let's see  who are
the most taller babies here in Mexico..
Who are the higher babies in Mexico
in these last couple of years
Let’s search for the entity
of Birth ...
entity of birth .
and for the ones that are familiar with  SQL let’s group them..
by that column
entity of birth ...
to order
the first column in order
descendant.
We’ll see the
state that has
the tallest babies in Mexico.
Bet, bets .. in 2.7 seconds Query analyzed 200
MB data.
00:08:27,619 --> 00:08:30,149
Sinaloa has the highest babies
Sinaloa and then Sonora right?
Sonora and with a difference
quite large between 52.33
average and 51.98. Very tall people
in Sinaloa! At least the babies!
And where is the shortest babies?
We can reverse the question, right? Sure! Or we go to
the last row.
There are many babies with no specific birth region
and those are the shortest.
but we can find Yucatan.
Yucatan!
Here we can find the smaller babies Yucatan
very interesting ...
This way we have a quick
overview
And we can further discuss, adding columns, crossing this information. Really interesting what we propose there
Felipe, I would wonder…
What else could we ask, right?
because the community wants
to ask..
Want to contact Felipe ..
We can also do this through our social focus
Google.com/+DesarrolladoresGoogle.
I also know  that you’re in stack
overflow. All the question that you may have
when you’re using
BigQuery, something that you want to
optimize
you can to stackoverflow.com. You’ll find many engineers
of Biquery, there is a community.
It works in English
but they can also find you there.
so here is the link to stackoverflow.com
where we can do these consultations.
We reviewed
open data sets, we were talked
about BiQuery, we had fun with this
Local set, here in Mexico,
of births
And now we'll take a break. In the
upcoming block we will continue
analyzing data, we will see
much more about Bigquery.
in this case there is a surprise
respect to the wikipedia, that
we can use and much more of BigQuery.
We have an impressive amount of information
and if’s not, then, what are you waiting for? Upload it!
And if you want to me make it public, do so and share it!
Exactly so we invite everyone to
to share your information
and keep working on Biquery.
We’ll be right back with Google Developers Show
00:10:44,900 --> 00:10:49,470
Welcome to Google Developers Show,
we keep enjoying the presence of Felipe Hoffa, our
BigQuery expert,
Big Data in this particular case ..
We previously discussed about open data sets of birth
In the city of Mexico. We worked on different querys and
how to upload the data. Now we’ll continue to work with more
complexity
Let's play, let's play with this data! Of course we’ll be
sharing all the work that Felipe did
about putting together the data of 2008 to
2013. It will be available down here
so you, that is following this show,
can use these data
and share knowladge. Shall we continue?
I have some doubts about Mexico’s births
I want to know what is the peak
day of births
From 2008 to 2013?
Can we do that? Let’s do it. It’s very simple.
Everyone who want to analyze
these data can enter the URL
that we have here..
I see your console now. Yes, so we bring our
Date of birth
We select Date of birth
of the child, not the mother. Ok ..
And we will ...
group
by date of birth. Very well ..
And let’s count how many babies
were born  every day
As we have many days in the past few years,
we will make a thousand limit
and we will sort by the second column
in descending order
We analyzed 145 megs
in 2.3 seconds
and we can see the day that more children were borned
is September 18
September, a spring month for some regions..
Here we are in summer..
Interesting, so September is the month
for more numbers of births.
September 18, 2013 for all of you happy birthdays!
Happy one year! Congratulations to you all!
And as you can see the date that follows to it is
the September 14, 2011
the September 18, 2009
we have a ...
patronage around
18 and September 20 of these
year... Exactly September is a magical month
but
we should also see what is the month
or days
with less number of births.
To do so we can order the data
in the other direction
Let’s see
Two seconds .. Wow ..
You can see here that as we are working with real data
data sometimes does not always come
completely clean
and in this case there are three, four babies
that the birth date was entered
with hyphens or spaces, and are counted differently ..
But we can see that the date with
fewer births within the past
year with
3719 birhs is on 25 December 2008
So December
looks like ...
We can search for the component
of day and we can see
month by month little or year by year
and we can see for example what happens in each month.
Great, let’s keep working on it..
In this case I kept it as
strink
each date, I could have saved
like another field, but I inserted as
strink. Because of this I can,
for example,
leave only the
five characters
that are in the left.
Let's see what it results..
Five characters left
are for the day and the month .. Exactly.
You can see that the more popular
day here to have babies in 2008 and 2013 was 10
September. We continue with September!
But if I only want to see the month, I will take only the
two characters of the right.
You see this is all very quick to analyze and
change .. and we have
the month with most babies
is September. Exactly.
To graph this ...
I could download my data as
as CSV. Ok, but I'll do a simple copy / paste day today
to make it more simple.
There are just 12 data
and here I want to graph it.
We have a spreadsheet. I can do a chart
with Google Spreadsheet
We will insert ..
one chart
We can see it here.
We’re using a graphic of lines
And this chart is very strange..
Let's do something different…
I’ll return to BigQuery
I could also do the changes
in
in the spreadsheet. I will
order in this case…
instead of ordering
by months of the most births I will sort by the
number of the month. It's okay!
And let’s see what we see ordered month by month
We first have January, then
all other months.
I'm going back to do my copy / paste.
Is important that everyone understands that we’re
doing this live!
Processing data ....
This is the month, this is the number of borned.
Let's take back this information, we will insert
a chart
00:16:45,760 --> 00:16:52,760
And here we can see clearly
as the number of births fluctuates
month to month, from January to December,
Be careful with it .. I was going to say ..
What about the graphics not starting
in zero, right?
They are tricky.
But here I can request to
starts the axil at zero. And here we can see
quite clear how the number of births fluctuates throughout
the year , being September our top month
and December the less one.
December to January the month with fewer births. Is
really fantastic, seeing Felipe
work here
taking data with us
processing the data using BigQuery. In seconds we have tendency
and we know much more of about births
in this particular case that we are seeing Felipe.
I invite you to continue experimenting,
There are interesting queries such as if we have the entity's birth
mother and where the child was borned
we can see migration in Mexico ...
and many interesting things.
But I leave that task to you!
Exactly, continue with your development
Using BigQuery, sharing that knowledge
as we do here at Google Developers Show
Let’s keep sharing with Felipe  about
Bigquery and Massive Data analysis!